in Hawaii more evacuation orders have
been given to residents who live in the
path of lava pouring out of the Kilauea
volcano already thousands of people have
been forced to flee to safety dozens of
homes have been destroyed anyone who
stays could face arrest dangerous lava
flows have closed sections of the main
highway Kilauea has been erupting for
four weeks and that is hurting a big
business for the island tourism here's
Carter Evans with the latest river of
molten rock burning a new path to the
ocean people in nearby Kapoho have spent
the last two days packing up their homes
anticipating the lava would cut off the
last road out of their community in
Leilani estates Robert and Kristi Marin
want to stay as long as possible but
with a lava fountain four blocks away
from their home they're not spending
their nights here authorities now say
anyone who defies a new mandatory
evacuation order in Leilani estates
could be arrested the lava zone is
becoming increasingly dangerous
especially near the main fissure when
the lava comes it consumes everything in
its path but sometimes it burns these
trees down slowly you can see where it's
surrounded a trunk over there further to
the left that one is about to fall over
longtime residents say this could be the
new normal
what do you think the next month is
gonna look like unfortunately you're
probably looking at it and the dramatic
images broadcast around the world are
having another impact on tourism it was
kind of a shocker for us because this is
really a normal occurrence Ross Burgess
with the Big Island Visitors Bureau he
says the eruption impacts less than 1%
of the island but still hotel bookings
are down 50% even in Kona on the other
side of the island cruise ships are also
canceling port calls that's actually the
largest impact that we've had
specifically to the island is the
immediate lack of port calls both in
Hilo and in Kona and that really hurts
our mom-and-pop operations so do people
need to worry oh absolutely not
if you have plans to come to Hawaii
definitely keep those plans if you
hadn't had
right now it's actually the time to
start looking at it the Hawaii Volcanoes
National Park is the number one
attraction here but it's closed
indefinitely and scientists aren't
offering a prediction for how long this
eruption might last they are saying they
do expect more steam explosions at the
volcano's summit for CBS this morning
Saturday Carter Evans the Big Island of
Hawaii